élu lors des dernières élections
municipales
mohamed boudjellaba est maire de givors
depuis à peine deux mois
lorsqu'il reçoit un courrier de quatre
pages dont il publie quelques extraits à
les fous l'camp [ __ ] si tu ne veux
pas brûler comme une merguez
on sait encore se servir d'une
mitraillette tu sais comment ça fait une
bombe dans une habitation
ça fait boum avant de rendre public ces
insultes et ses menaces
l'élu écologiste a hésité trois jours
durant pour lui dénoncé ces propos
injurieux
c'est aussi leur donner un écho et se
désigner lui-même comme arabe et
musulman je suis un élu de la république
donc en tant que français je suis né
dans cette ville
j'ai vécu dans cette ville donc je suis
le fruit de cette ville je suis avant
tout un élu maire de la république pas
un maire musulman je suis un maire
français d'une ville française
le courrier traite aussi yasmine goigs à
la mer fraîchement élu du 1er
arrondissement de lyon de fatma un
prénom féminin arabe courant devenu
synonyme de domestique pour les colons
français installés en afrique du nord
les motivations racistes du ou des
auteurs ne font aucun mystère
je pense que je dois déranger certains
groupes
manifestement je dérange le fait que je
sois moi m budget là bas soit mère
devenue une ville de 20 mille habitants
ça dérange certains groupes dès qu'il en
prend connaissance le préfet de région
condamne ces insultes sur twitter suivi
dès le lendemain par de très nombreux
membres de la classe politique et au
delà le ministre de la justice celui de
l'intérieur mais aussi au sein de
l'opposition des réactions comme celle
d'antoine méliès élus rassemblement
national à givors c'est juste
inacceptables toute la lumière doit être
faite pour retrouver l'auteur et le
traduire en justice
une enquête est ouverte pour retrouver
le ou les auteurs du courrier